Dr. C. Medici has a protocol for colorectal cancer which includes sodium bicarbonate
enemas. I'm all four sodium bicarbonate enemas for colorectal cancer. Personally I have not done them
but I would say that there is really no downside to doing them really. He recommends six days on six
days off for four cycles with instructions on the below website, this website here and how to do that.
What are your thoughts specifically? The enemas have you worked with us in clinical experience.
I have, we've had people do sodium bicarbonate enemas. Everybody that works with us is doing a lot
of different things so I don't know that there was major changes with that but you have a very good,
the person who asked this question has a very good track record of kind of you know seed you know
what's working and what's not working and kind of documenting their care so I would jump on board
with this a great audition possible addition to your profile. As far as the IV sodium bicarbonate,
I can't really comment on that. I don't know how you would do that. Your blood has all these
bicarbonate systems. I don't know if you could do IV. I don't know if I'm even more sorry.